So I saw this,
and it's literally just a video of this girl who was, like,
taking her Aquaphor and filling it into, like,
little lip gloss thingies.
You know what I mean?
Like, little, like,
see, like, those little, like,
lip gloss tubes, right?
But Aquaphor is really dense.
It doesn't really work like that.
Let me put you on something even better. Okay,
basically, this is a Burt's Bees pop socket.
And it comes with, like,
Burt's Bees little Chapstick,
but I don't like it.
I think it's too waxy,
so I just fill it with Aquaphor instead.
I need you to understand, I cannot function without this phone case.
So this is a Burt's Bees pop socket.
And do you see that this.
This is my Aquaphor.
I cannot go anywhere without it.
I have this, like,
big thing of Aquaphor,
and, like, once a month, maybe I just, like,
squeeze them in here, right,
and I refill it.
You can be more precise.
I don't care enough to. Um,
this. Like, I, I,
I have a big phone, and I can't,
I just can't use my phone without a pop socket.
Um, and this, like,
life changer. Um,
that's why I have my listening angel on here.
And I'm Bulgarian,
and every New Year, we have this, like,
little bread that we break,
and we have, like,
little, like,
messages. What,
what the New Year will give to us was, like, health, wealth,
luck, travel,
whatever. And I Got luck.
And I was keeping my phone.
Um, also,
this is all the super glue to get the kids on. Anyways,
not important.
Point is life changer.
I cannot recommend enough. How much I love, like,
this little thing.
Since discovering it,
I have not had a phone without it.
Um, so, yeah,
you're welcome.